Yes! Yes! Amazing! Vielen Dank! Ah, Richard, vielen, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Reinkommen, für diesen Aufmacher. Nicht nur machst du die Folge auf, sondern auch unsere Herzen, für unsere Vergangenheit, für unsere Nostalgie. Vielen, vielen Dank für diese kleine Erinnerung, mit der wir in diese, ja, dann doch vielleicht legendäre Folge starten, denn heute ist Folge 355! Alles Gute zur 350. Folge, Stefan. 350? 50, genau. Vielen, vielen Dank an alle Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer. Wir wollen euch heute ein dickes, dickes Geschenk machen. Vielen Dank, dass wir... Ja, wir haben deswegen extra einen neuen Gast wieder eingeladen. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass er hier ist. Herzlich willkommen, ähm ... Bono. Ja, ey, Leute. Ja, dreiundfünfzig Folgen. Bald ist es so weit, dass wir jeden Tag eine Folge hören können. Ich freue mich eigentlich eher auf Folge 365. Das ist unglaublich wenig eigentlich dafür, dass wir das schon wie lange neun Jahre machen oder so Da haben wir aber die ersten Jahre haben wir ein bisschen, bis wir die erste Seinfeld-Staffel, die irgendwie nur vier Folgen hat, ist so das erste Jahr haben wir anscheinend nur zwölf Folgen aufgenommen. Ich glaube, wir haben so alle, alle Jubeljahre, mal so alles Halbjahr haben wir uns mal zusammengesetzt und kurz besprochen. Es ist ein relativ neues Phänomen, das wir so regelmäßig auch veröffentlichen. Ja, der Wochenzwang, die gute alte Woche, bestimmt unser Leben. Bald haben wir 365 Folgen. Und keine Stimme mehr. Und keine Lust mehr zu sprechen. Daran denkt ihr, weil das ist ja so, wenn Fußballer irgendwie noch so traben, merkt man, ah gut, die wechseln bei den Vereinen und so. Bei Podcastern, wenn angefangen wird zu nuscheln, wenn die Vokale nicht mehr, genau, dann will er ausgewechselt werden oder hat irgendwie einen Spotify-Exklusiv-ertrag überschrieben oder sowas. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen, Flontin ist einfach nur saufaul. Ja, saufaul und ich habe kaum noch Wörter übrig. Mein Köcher ist leer, ich habe, glaube ich, noch so 3000 Wörter übrig, weil ich auch so viel alleine rede. Ich führe viele Selbstgespräche, viel auch nochmal, weil ich verstehe Dinge besser, wenn ich sie erkläre und ausspreche und wenn ich irgendwas nicht verstehe, dann versuche ich das so. Baumwolle, Schnellwäsche, Schnellwäsche, Baumwolle. Je heisser das Wasser, desto weniger Flecken. Desto kleiner die Kleidung. Je grösser ich bin, desto heisser die Kleidung, die ich trage. Was ist das für eine Anleitung, die du liest? Was für eine Kinderanleitung ist das? Das klingt so wie so Eltern, die in den Urlaub gefahren sind. Und das habe ich mal gemacht, da war ich zum ersten Mal alleine gelassen worden von meinen Eltern. Ich weiß nicht, wo die waren. Auf jeden Fall waren die so lange weg, dass ich die Spülmaschine zum ersten Mal betätigen musste. Oh, großer Stefan. Großer Stefan, ganz gross, kam so gerade obendran. Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich war ich schon älter, weil sonst lässt man das Kind ja nicht alleine. Naja, da habe ich jedenfalls einen grossen Schrecken bekommen, als ich plötzlich diesen Spül-Tab herausfielen hörte. Oh ja. Und dachte mir, ich habe es nicht richtig zugemacht. Ja, ich habe das Spül-Tab-Dingen nicht richtig zugemacht. Es liest sich einmal einrasten, es hat geklickt. Ich dachte mir, okay, das ist genau wie auf der Anleitung geschrieben steht. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, shit, shit, shit. Das kommt in der Werbung nicht vor. Und dann habe ich es zugemacht, angemacht und nach der Zeit wiesch die Maschine und plötzlich ploppte das Ding heraus. Und ich dachte, da habe ich meine Eltern angerufen. Mayday, Mayday, der Waschgang läuft noch. Ich wiederhole, der Waschgang läuft noch. Was soll ich tun? Nebraska, Nebraska. Und die Mutter guckte meinen Vater an, nickt einmal und steht dann auf aus dem Restaurant, weil ich habe das Code-Wort gesagt. N-Wort. Nickt zu dem Kellner zu, der Kellner nickt auch und er verlässt den Raum. Nebraska. Code 5-9. Scheiße, spül mal Spül-Tab. Das ist ja das Beste im Zug immer. Da gibt es ja auch diese Code-Rufe, dieser Ruf 78. Und jedes Mal denke ich mir, soll ich den Gag machen und schnell aufspringen und irgendwo hinrennen. Einfach so, das ist jetzt genau mein Code. Das ist jetzt, wo ich aktiv, dann mach was sehr Spezifisches, um den Nitznachbarn zu verwirren. Zum Beispiel Code 78. Und was du machst, ist dann deine Wasserflasche nehmen und schütteln, aufmachen und auskippen. Und du sagst, machen Sie es auch, machen Sie es auch. Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell. Weil das ganz Spezifisches ist. Oder du setzt deinen Cap andersrum auf.
Ja, irgendwas muss man ja machen so.
Du willst ja dem Code Folge leisten.
Es ist der Code, verdammt noch mal, es ist der Code.
Man muss was machen.
Code 78, also was du machst, ist deine Hoodie-Kapuze überziehen
und an beiden Kordeln ziehen, bis das Gesicht langsam verschwindet,
wie South Park.
So alle Kordeln festziehen. Ja, genau. Schnürsenkel nochmal fester ziehen, Hoodie und Jacke und alles festziehen. Okay. Ich glaube, ich würde sofort nachmachen als Sitznachbund. Ja klar, natürlich. Wenn jemand den Code so gut kennt, denke ich mir, oh. Oder du kannst natürlich auch zu jemandem hingehen und sagen, übrigens Code 78 heißt Schuhe anziehen. Wenn da wieder so jemand sockig unterwegs ist. Übrigens, Code 78 heißt, du musst mir deine Nummer geben. Oh, okay, interessant. Du bist wieder im Flirt-Mode, habe ich das Gefühl. Nee, aber das wäre doch nicht schlecht. Ja, das stimmt. Also es wäre super unangemessen, wenn Code 78 heißt, dass wir einen Unfall hatten oder sowas. Ja. Dann wäre es unglaublich merkwürdig, wenn man dann sagt.
Wahrscheinlich die drei Schaffner, die gerade zuhören, sitzen auch sehr ernst gerade da, weil sie wissen, wofür Code 78 steht und denken sich, ja, lacht nur.
Aber 78 heißt es, Bordbistro ist wieder zu, die Mikrowelle bleibt kalt und all die hungrigen Fahrgäste und ihr Schinkenkäse-Sandwich wollen.
Herbert, Herbert, alles Gute.
Sie kommen und, nein, Sie hören nicht auf und Sie wollen, ihr Gäste, die Bäder.
Weisst du noch?
Ich hätte zweimal einen 78.
Hab ich dir jemals davon erzählt?
78 vor Hamm.
Richtig.
2002 war das.
Ich hatte einen 78 vor Hamm.
Das war bis Robert zu. Die Mikrowelle ging nicht. Was ist denn passiert? Wie bist du da ausgekommen, verdammt nochmal, Gerhard? Ich habe das Mikrofon in die Hand genommen und gesagt, Code 78. Und? Und gehofft, dass jemand kommt. Und kam jemand, haben die Leute richtig reagiert? Der uns aus dieser Situation herausholt. Und die Vollidioten haben nur ihre Wasserflaschen ausgeschüttet. Sie haben nur ihre Wasserflaschen ausgeschüttet und ich fest... Das Wasser kam mir entgegen, flutartig. Flutartig entgegen, die Türen aufgemacht, weil der Hamsgeruch stand in der Nacht und bezog langsam alle Waggons. Und dann kam jemand, ein Elektriker. Ich hätte nur die Mikrowelle ausgestöpselt. Das war mein Fehler.
Also ein 180er?
Es war eigentlich ein 180er, getarnt als 78er.
Ich glaube, das war das Näheste, als ich wirklich mal in einem Weltuntergang war, als in einem ICE die Toilette übergeflossen ist und es rausgesuppt ist aus der Kabine und durch Beschleunigung und Bremsen sich diese braune Flüssigkeit einfach immer weiter die Gänge runtergearbeitet hat und die Leute langsam Panik bekommen haben, weil man konnte ab einem gewissen Punkt den Bereich nicht mehr überqueren. Und die einen waren dann wirklich in der Falle, weil da war dann nur noch ein Waggon und es kam immer die Leute wirklich einfach so Vietnam Flashbacks, haben sich versucht zu retten irgendwie, hinten haben sich gegenseitig die Sätze weggenommen. Vietnam-Flashbacks, weil Vietnam war ja das grösste Problem, war ja, dass da sich verstopfte Toiletten langsam den Weg Richtung zu dir gebar haben. Rolling Thunder damals, ja ja, ich weiß noch. Ich liebe den Geruch von überquillenden Filetten am Morgen. Das ist Vietnam, wie ich gewählt. Ja, nee. 350, also wir sind nah dran. Die 365 würde mich, die würde ich eher noch feiern, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Weil eigentlich ist ja 365 die einzige Zahl, die sozusagen wirklich konstante ist. Ich frag mich, warum nicht bei diesen ganzen Zahlen okkulten Leuten so. 666, 23, 42, 68, 17, 9, 4, ja, das ist der Stefan Kult. 420, 69. Genau, warum bei solchen Leuten? Nee, weil wir müssen auch andere Leute abholen. Wir müssen auch Leute mit dem Humor abholen, die vielleicht über 69 lachen. Die einfach über eine Zahl lachen. Ja, genau. Ich bewundere das ja manchmal, dass jemand eine 69 sieht und einfach lache. Das ist eine Zahl. Aber du bist einfach vielleicht auch Mathe-Fan. Es ist einfach, der einzige Rettungsring, den ein Mathe hinwirft, ist, pass auf, du musst Stochastik lernen, du musst Bruchrechnung lernen, du musst die Mitternachtsformel lernen, aber keine Angst, wir haben eine lustige Zahl, okay? Okay, wir haben einige lustige Zahlen.
Okay, jetzt Kurvendiskussion.
Wo ist der Nullpunkt?
Denk an die lustige Zahl, die kommt danach, die kommt danach, die kommt danach.
So ein Hund, der mit so einer Angel irgendwie so eine Wurst vorne die Nase hält und dann zu etwas bringt.
Du hast, mach mir den Nullpunkt und dann eines Tages 69 und er rastet aus.
Wow, jetzt kommt das Podcast. Super! Nee, stimmt. Mathe hat nichts zu bieten, ausser das und eine fantastische inhärente Logik, die mir das Herz höher schlägen lässt. Mathe fand ich toll, hat immer Spaß gemacht, dieser Moment, wenn man was verstanden hat und alles ergibt Sinn in diesem, man denkt, oh, ich bin so clever, ich habe die Welt verstanden, aber man hat eigentlich nur diesen sehr speziellen Mini-Mini-Mini-Bereich in der Mathematik verstanden. Du hast verstanden, dass du Zahlen in eine Formel einsetzen musst und sie in den Taschenringer tippst. Das war's. Es ist wie, ich habe die Übersetzung gelernt oder so, oder ich habe so einen Cheatcode auswendig gelernt, durch was ich jetzt, dann kann ich mit diesen Zahlen das von mir Verlangte vollbringen. Nice, aber das fühlt sich gut an, das fühlt sich gut an. Und ich weiß auch nicht, warum es, aber ich habe so Spaß daran, dass es eine klare Antwort gibt. Es hat sich von allen anderen Schulfächern immer abgehoben durch dieses, auch Mathelehrer muss auch entspannt sein, weil du halt nicht diese nervigen Diskussionen mit Schülern führst, irgendwie so aber ich habe hier doch irgendwie alle Punkte angesprochen, die von mir in der Fragestellung verlangt waren und sowas, nein bei Mathe geht es nur um klare Zahlen. Die Antwort war fünf und du hast 866.413 geschrieben. Ich weiß, aber es ist ein Folgefehler. Ja, aber die Zahl ist weit weg. Es war ein Folgefehler. Fünf klein, du hast achthunderttausend. Ja, das ist so weit weg, das ist nur sechs. Aber es gab auch Momente, wo ich raushatte fünf und die Antwort war irgendwie ein Bruch, dreiundzwanzig, fünfhundertneunzigstel Kilogramm und ich hatte fünf. Ich erinnere mich noch, ich habe Geld verdient mit Mathe. Ich habe als Kind Geld verdient mit Mathe, weil ich schon da meine Pedantenader irgendwie so gefunden habe, weil ich habe mal aufgeschnappt auf dem Schulhof oder mein Vater hat es mir beigebracht, dass sich zwei Geraden in der Unendlichkeit schneiden. Also dieses klassische Unendlichkeitsthema denkt man ja so gerne drüber nach, aber dann die Idee, dass sich Parallelen, dass sich zwei Parallelen in der Unendlichkeit schneiden.
Man lernt ja in der Schule ganz klassisch, Parallelen schneiden sich nie, aber dann ist man irgendwann so weit und sagt, doch, in der Unendlichkeit schneiden sie sich schon. Was? Nee, aber why? Achso, und jetzt dieses Wissen.
Das war ein Unsinn.
Mit diesem Wissen bin ich zu meinem guten Freund Yannis hingegangen und habe gesagt, du pass auf, mal so nebenbei, während alle anderen über Mädels gesprochen haben, habe ich gesagt, du übrigens zwei Parallelen schneiden sich in Endlichkeit, er hat gesagt, ne. Er hat gesagt, pass auf, wir wetten jetzt um zwei Mark. Du hättest jede Zahl sagen können, aber du hast dann gesagt zwei Mark. Ich hatte alle natürlichen Zahlen zu meiner Verfügung. Ich habe mich für Menge ist gleich zwei. Für jemanden, der sich mit der Unendlichkeit beschäftigt, Hast du sehr früh aufgehört bei der zwei. Das stimmt, aber okay. Aber du musst sagen, für ein Kind ist das ein Vermögen. Und dann sind wir tatsächlich zu unserer Mathelehrerin hingegangen und die sagt, ja, hallo Frau Grumpenmüller, wir haben eine Frage. Ja, stimmt es, dass sich zwei Parallelen in Unendlichkeit schneiden und sie so wirklich ein bisschen so, er ist der Auserwählt. Sie haben das verbotene Wissen. Und dann drückt sie auf den Knopf und sagt, Code 78. Ihr habt aber nicht in den verbotenen Schrank geschaut, oder? Nein, nein, nein, nein, und dann meinte sie so, ja, das stimmt. Why stimmt das? Aber erklär es mir, weil ich verstehe es nicht, ich würde auch jetzt wieder gegen dich werden. Ich kann dir das doch nicht erklären, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist einfach nur, das ist, das ist einfach nur, das ist, das ist einfach nur, das ist, das ist einfach nur, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist so, ja, das stimmt. Why stimmt das? Aber erklär es mir. Weil ich verstehe es nicht. Ich würde auch jetzt wieder gegen dich werden. Ich kann dir das doch nicht erklären. Das ist einfach nur Partywissen. Warum schneiden die sich in der Unendlichkeit? Ja, weil es die Unendlichkeit ist. Da ist alles möglich. Das Interessante ist sogar, sie schneiden sich nur ein einziges Mal. Das ist so ein Funt. Sie schneiden sich nicht in beide Richtungen. Oh, jetzt wird wütend recherchiert. Stefan hat sein, ich kann das nicht fassen Gesicht, und tippt jetzt, hackt jetzt gerade in die Tastatur. Oh, Euclid. Um es mit Euclid zu sagen, parallel sind gerade Linien, die in derselben Ebene liegen und dabei, wenn man sie nach beiden Seiten ins Endliche verlängert, auf keine anderen Treffen. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Das ist das Paul-Kersufo. Ja, und okay, Euclid ist auf deiner Seite. Aber ich habe Frau Grumpengröbel auf meiner Seite, okay? Und dein Vater. Und dann kannst du mal schauen. Das ist so dumm. Ich hasse diesen Funfact, weil er mich wütend macht, weil ich es nicht verstehe, es vielleicht stimmt, ich es aber sehr schlecht googeln kann und es keine klare Antwort gibt, außer jetzt Euclid, was mir schon ehrlich gesagt ziemlich in die Karten spielt, und die Erklärungen sind dann mit Formeln, die ich nicht verstehe, ausgedrückt. Ich hasse jetzt alles an diesem Funfact. Das ist kein Funfact, das ist ein Bad Times Fact. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich glaube, so vor einem Monat oder so hätte ich dir noch was dazu sagen können, weil ich habe mal so eine Geschichte gesehen, so einen Vortrag, weil es gibt ja, das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr zusammen. Aber du kannst ja jede unendliche Zahl reinsetzen, angenommen du hast Stefan, halt mal kurz deinen Maul. Halt mal kurz deine Fresse, okay? Weil folgend ist, du kannst ja Gleichungen aufstellen für Parallelen, ne? Ja. Und da kannst du ja jede x-beliebige Zahl reinsetzen. Und das kann ja unendliche Zahlen sein. Und egal, was für eine Zahl du reinsetzt, die würden niemals würde Gleichung A gleich Gleichung B, halt Schnittpunkt, halt Schnittpunkt sein. In Unendlichkeit schon. Ne, eben nicht. Da sind die Regeln anders. Eben nicht. Das ist wie Las Vegas, da gelten gewisse Gesetze nicht. Der ist halt einfach strange. Da gibt's einen zweiten Eiffelturm. Da gibt's noch mal das White ... äh, das ... White Castle? Wie heißt das noch mal? Das Weiße Haus. Da gibt's alles noch mal. Ja, natürlich, der Satz, es gibt nur einen Eiffelturm, ist technisch korrekt, aber in Las Vegas halt dann doch noch einen. Weißt du, da ist halt alles anders, das ist halt einfach strange. Du brauchst halt auch die Absurdität, um die Normalität auch zu genießen zu können. Herr und Frau Will, also ich habe sie hier, also mein Name ist immer Frau Grubenmüller, wir haben uns so noch nicht kennengelernt. Ah ja, sie sind die Mathelehrerin von Grubenmüller. Mathelehrerin, genau. Also es ist ein bisschen unangenehm. Ist alles in Ordnung? Nee, also genau, ich habe ein Problem ein bisschen mit ihrem Sohn, also vielleicht hat ihr Sohn auch schon ein bisschen was erzählt. Oh, worum geht es denn? Ähm, ja er hat so ein bisschen den Cheatcode entdeckt, und zwar bei allen, weil normalerweise gibt es ja in der Mathematik nur eine Antwort. Jetzt hat er aber verstanden, dass man, wenn man mit Las Vegas argumentiert, man immer Recht hat, weil klar, wir alle wissen, kennen den Satz, in Las Vegas ist alles möglich. Moment mal, das erklärt, warum er sich letzte Woche ein Snickers King Size gekauft hat. Wir haben uns schon gefragt, woher das Geld herkommen kann. Eigentlich sind wir relativ konservativ mit dem Taschengeld und jetzt plötzlich kommt er, er hat eine komplette Smarties-Packung gekauft. Das muss es sein. Heißt es, mein Sohn hat die Unendlichkeit gesehen? Ist er der Auserwählte? Glaube, ihr Sohn ist der Auserwählte. He's the chosen one. Ich unterrichte auch Englisch. Ja, wie ist er so in Englisch? Gut, okay. Da machen wir uns keine Gedanken. Aufgeweckt. Unangenehm, wenn man zwei Fächer hat. In einem ist man sehr gut, in einem ist man sehr schlecht, aber gleicher Lehrer. Lehrer kriegen das nicht hin. Ja, oder ist es nicht schlimmer, wenn das Kind in beiden Fächern schlecht ist, wenn man denkt, vielleicht liegt es an mir? Vielleicht fördere ich das Kind nicht. Ich bin das nicht gefördert. Ich dachte jetzt eher aus SchülerInnenperspektive, hast du natürlich dann auch in einem guten Fach so gut wie keine Chance, weil du glaube ich nicht dein Image überqueren kannst. Du kriegst den Lehrer, die Lehrer nicht dazu, dich, das Bild von dir zu ändern. Ändere mal generell. Hast du es schon mal bei irgendwem geschafft, ein Bild von dir zu ändern? Ich habe noch nie geschafft, ein Bild von mir zu ändern.
Leute stecken dich in Schubladen seit dem ersten Moment, wo sie dich gesehen haben und die ersten drei Sätze, die du sprichst. Und wenn du dich da versprochen hast, versuch dann mal, das zu ändern.
Wenn du dich in den ersten drei Sätzen zweimal stolperst, gegen die Tür rennst und dich versprichst, dann hast du verloren. Das stimmt. Du kommst da kaum nochmal zurück.
Du kommst da nicht raus. Es gibt kein Reset. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, pass auf, ich versuche mich zurückzuarbeiten. Aber es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel bei den, wir müssen natürlich unbedingt über die Oscars reden, die ganze ganze Reihe davon, die Oscar-Buzz. Okay, wir reden von den Oscars letzte Woche. Also wir kommen Late to the Party, the Podcast. Ach, das lief schon, Podcast. Und da gibt es ja auch das Gegenstück, die Rezzis, die Himbeere, die Goldene Himbeere. Und da gibt es tatsächlich so einen Comeback-Preis. Also jemand, der immer schlecht war, aber plötzlich gut wird, kriegt dann so einen Re-Evaluation oder so einen Comeback-Preis, um dem zu zeigen, nee, du bist jetzt nicht mehr, wir machen uns nicht mehr über dich lustig. Aber ist es nicht ein Negativpreis? Genau. Die Goldenen-Hilmeer ist eigentlich ein Negativpreis,
aber angenommen jetzt irgendjemand kriegt jedes
Jahr den Negativpreis, irgendwie furchtbar,
keine Ahnung, irgendwie Uwe Boll
oder so, und dann haut Uwe Boll mal
so einen richtig geilen Film raus, so wirklich
so richtig gut, dann kriegt er auch extra
so einen, nicht wir haben uns getäuscht
Preis, sondern
du kommst zurück, Preis. Aber wie doof, also
wir nehmen das so ein bisschen zurück. Wie schwer zu erklären, wie schwer den Grosseltern zu erklären, dass man einen Negativpreis bekommen hat, aber aus anderen Gründen, und zwar dieser Negativpreis ist doch ein, es ist wie Eltern Twitch zu erklären, eigentlich oder sowas. Es ist so, weil wie doof, also ich finde, wenn du ein Negativpreis bist, bleib bei deinen Leisten, bleib bei deinen Raspberries, fang nicht an, jetzt irgendwie positive Preise zu vergleichen es ist so schlechter der himbeere ich meine wir alle sind uns einig dass die himbeere die schlechtere aus erdbeeren kirsche himbeere ist nicht okay die beste top drei rote bären rote bären auf johannes bär haben wir auch noch vergiss johannes ich rede nur von kirsche erdbeere himbeere ja der klassische joghurt mit der Ecke, drei verschiedene Fruchtfühlingen, das Dreigestirn quasi. Okay, auf Platz drei. Die Marmeladen auch, klassische Marmeladen, drei. Ja, auf Platz drei die Erdbeere. Ich finde die zu süß, overrated, viel zu sehr gesehen. Als Kind wird man super früh schon damit auseinandergesetzt, dann wird es inflationär, wirst du mit Erdbeeren beworfen. Brauche ich nicht, ist mir zu süss, die kriege ich woanders besser und nuancierter. Ich glaube, ich habe Erdbeere auch noch nie wirklich reif gegessen. Der hat immer noch so einen grünen Strunk und es ist immer so ein bisschen kauig. Es mag sein, dass es auch in Deutschland liegt, dass die hier besonders scheiße sind und die woanders nicht so scheiße sind, aber die Erdbeere sind hier besonders scheiße. Also ich lese daraus, du hast der Erdbeere viele Chancen gegeben und wurdest immer wieder enttäuscht. Stimmt das, Stefan? Nicht immer wieder enttäuscht, aber zumal auch beim Frühstück, wir kommen gleich auf meinen Gewinner, aber wenn man beim Frühstück sitzt und dann hat man, kriegt man, man ist nicht zu Hause, man weiss nicht, was man bekommt, man kriegt aber eine rote Marmelade hinzugeschoben und es ist Erdbeere. Enttäuschung. Ich stehe ja dann auf, inzwischen, habe ich nicht immer gemacht, inzwischen stehe ich auf und verlasse dann den Frühstückstisch. Okay, das ist klar. Ohne Erklärung, ohne Code 404 und sowas. Ich stehe auf, Erdbeer-Alarm, gehe raus. Aber zum Beispiel, die Erdbeere hat schon, finde ich, ihren Platz. Peanut Butter Jelly ist immer Erdbeere. Da kann man sich... Ach hier, grosse, wirklich Thesen in die Welt gestiegen. Nee, da kannst du nicht Himbeeren nehmen oder so. Das geht nicht. Du brauchst es da schon. Du brauchst es da schon. So einen Erdbeerkuchen ist schon okay, aber da gebe ich dir recht. Und auf Platz zwei für mich die Himbeere. Himbeere, ich bin ab einem gewissen Punkt bin ich imgestiegen bei der Marmelade von Erdbeere auf Himbeere. Einfach, aber das Problem an der Himbeere ist halt, dass du diese Körnerei hast. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, ich weiß nicht, was das soll, warum muss ich das essen? Oh, der Crisp, ich will doch den Crisp. Was? Diese Kerne? Bei einer Kirsche, das ist ja ein viel größeres Problem. Du hast einen grossen Kern. Ja, aber doch nicht in der Marmelade. Natürlich nicht, aber die erste doch, die stören doch nicht, die geben doch den gewissen Textur bei einer Himbeere. Doch, aber auch bei mir ist die Himbeere auf zwei. Aber man muss dazu sagen, der Abstand zwischen Himbeere und Erdbeere ist so groß, ausserdem Erdbeere komplett falsch ist nämlich eigentlich eine Nuss.
Das wäre der grösste Kontrapunkt, dass Leute die Chance haben, am Tisch zu sagen, dass es eigentlich eine Nuss ist.
Ja, das stimmt. Das interessiert niemanden.
Nein, das interessiert niemanden, stimmt auch wahrscheinlich nicht. Es ist der gleiche Realm, wie Parallelen schneiden sich in Unendlichkeit. Aber ich muss sagen, Kirschen, also Himbeeren esse ich lieber so, snack ich so weg. Das kann man mit Kirschen, finde ich, nicht so gut machen. Aber Himbeeren haben immer irgendwie so eine Tasche. Himbeeren haben immer so ein Loch. Innen drin. Ich habe das Gefühl, Himbeeren ist gar keine Sphäre, sondern eher so wie so ein Beutel. Also was war da mal drin? Der Stiel oben. Ja, aber ist die Himbeere dann innen hohl oder was? Die ist wie ein Apfel. Da war mal so ein Gehäuse drin. Nur beim Stiel zupfen ziehst du mehr dabei raus als die Liebes. Aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass das so rausgerissen ist. Das sieht noch so unberührt aus, wenn du mal in so eine Himbeere reinguckst. Ich habe jetzt diese Kamera, da kannst du auch in die Himbeere reingucken. Okay, mach das zumindest bevor du deine Ohren unterbruchst, okay? Aber was ich schön finde, also ich finde, Himbeeren sehen so andersweltlich aus. Die sehen aus, als würden sie von anderen Planeten kommen, weil die sind so perfekt, es ist so ein ganz ganz tolles unnatürliches Rot. Es ist wie so Helme. Die Aliens hatten ganz viele Ersatzhelme dabei, und der Container ist irgendwo abgestürzt. Es sind ja so organische Aliens, das wächst dann auch weiter. Aber nee, es ist komisch. Und eigentlich ist die Textur auch strange, oder? Dieses Pelzige. Ich find das toll, ein Geschmackirr, warum haben die Haare, warum haben manche, also sorry, aber jetzt auch mal, ich schau auf die Kiwi, ich meine, wir alle schauen auf die Kiwi und Kiwi sagen, Leute, ich möchte nicht immer geoutcalled werden, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, man muss sich unbedingt rasieren oder so, ich will jetzt gar nicht keine körperlichen Standards ansetzen, aber warum hat die Kiwi Haare, Tiere haben Haare, Ich meine, wir müssen nicht über die Biene reden, da finde ich schon strange. Aber warum hat jetzt plötzlich ein Obst auch noch gesagt, ne, ich hab Haare, ich hab hier so ein Schnurrbart. Aber die Kiwi schaut weiter. Rechts und jetzt ist nämlich die Kokosnuss. Oh, die haben Pferdeschwanz. Ey, jetzt sieht die, einfach wie Rusters, ganz grosse, ganz grosse Haarmenge einfach haben wachsen lassen. Aber Kiwi, das ist echt albern. Also warum, wozu brauchen die das? Ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Kiwi shaved, gebe ich jetzt mal ein. Hat jemand mal eine? Ja, ich glaube schon. Man kann die rasieren. Es ist wirklich wie menschliche Haut, ne? Eine Kiwi ist wirklich am nähersten an menschlicher Haut, glaube ich. Kiwi shaved? Macht man wahrscheinlich für so Rasiererwerbung, oder? Kann man immer gut eine Kiwi. Das ist genau wie diese Zahnbürste, die so gegen die Tomate drückt. Toll. Also ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden, was ich das sagen soll. Aber die Kiwi, glaube ich, kannst du immer gut rasieren. Ja, das stimmt. Das war immer das Oral-B-Zeichen am Ende. Aber gibt es dann auch... Mit der Oral-B-Qualität. Und dann hat man eine Tomate gehabt und die Zahnbürste. Ja. Und ich dachte immer nicht, also soll die Zahnbürste jetzt ... Ist es das Gel, dass sie nicht bricht, weil die da doch dann doll gegengedrückt wurde? Dann habe ich aber irgendwann verstanden, es liegt am ... das Zahnfleisch, die Tomate stellt das Zahnfleisch dar. Und die ... das ist natürlich dann schon eine geniale Idee. Es schützt die Tomate. Die Tomate wird nicht einfach zerdrückt. Sondern die Federung hält es davon. Aber man sieht schon, es ist schon eine Kraft, die dagegen wirkt, die man auch, glaube ich, braucht, um es zu säubern. Also ich glaube, das war so, es soll sagen, wir drücken den optimalen Druck auf das Zahnfleisch aus. Gibt es auch blonde Kiwi? Also gibt es dann da auch dann irgendwann so blonde oder so Strähnchen oder irgendwie Spikes oder sowas? Locken. Lockige Kiwi, das wäre doch auch gut, oder? Curls. Hi, hi. Ich bin Curly Kiwi und das ist ein guter, finde ich ein guter PR-Stand, oder? So eine Curly finde ich richtig gut. Ja, finde ich auch gut. So eine Locke, wie so ein Elvis oder James Dean. Einfach eine schön frisierte Ki eine schön frisierte Kiwi. Aber ich finde, also nur um das nochmal gesagt zu haben für das Protokoll, Obst sollte keine Haare haben, ich bin da eigentlich raus. Ich finde, das ist eine Absurdität der Natur. Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn sich irgendwann herausstellt, die Kiwi ist eigentlich ein Nagetier, biologisch, weil die machen eh was sie wollen. Und einfach, ja, sorry. Kiwis sind Schnecken. Technisch gesehen haben wir Nagetiere so definiert, dass sie Fell haben. Und deswegen muss die Kiwi eigentlich da rein. Und deswegen gehört ein Obstsalat und gehört eigentlich keine Kiwi rein, weil es eigentlich ein Nagetier ist. Fucking Biologen. Da hast du so einen Hass auf Biologen. Ich weiß nicht, weil die machen, was sie wollen. Es gibt irgendwie niemanden, es gibt keine Behörde oder so, denen auf die Finger haut. Doch, doch, doch. Ich finde, wir als Gesellschaft sollten auch die Möglichkeit haben, der Wissenschaft mal wirklich das Mikroskop aus der Hand zu schlagen und zu sagen, so geht's nicht, so machen wir das nicht. In der Schulzeit wird von der Gesellschaft den Nerds das Mikroskop aus der Fresse geschlagen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ja, nee, du hast mal wieder Unrecht, finde ich.
Okay, ja, weil ...
Mal wieder?
Nee, weil ich finde schon, also wie mit dem Parabelding,
parallelen Dingen gerade, weil ich glaube, es gibt Behörden,
die das checken.
Ja.
Und die dann sagen, so weit geht's nicht.
Die benennen doch auch ihre Tiere ständig
nach irgendwie so popkulturellen Sachen.
Ich meine, das ist eine ernste Wissenschaft.
Jetzt gibt es irgendwie so eine John-Wick-Schnecke oder irgendwie sowas. Ariana Grande, Blobfish. Ich meine, das ist schon witzig, aber das sind auch Gangs, die kein Mensch mehr versteht irgendwann. Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde das albern. Sorry, ich finde es albern. Eine John-Wick-Nacktschnecke, weil die so gut ihre Gegner umbringt. Ja, weil die irgendwie immer alle umbringt. Weil die irgendwie so 20 andere Schnecken gleichzeitig töten kann oder irgendwie sowas, weil die so krass ist oder was. Und weil sie spricht wie Ken Reeves. Schneckos John Wickers, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Ja, finde ich fantastisch. Ich wollte dir mal was erzählen, und zwar, ich habe es gerade vor der Aufnahme schon mal kurz erzählt, weil ich das nicht fassen kann, aber was ich nicht wusste ist, dass Franzosen, das machen die Deutschen nämlich auch, englische Filmtitel übersetzen ins Deutsche, aber in Deutschen ist es eher so, Science, Zeichen, aber der Film heißt immer noch Science, ja, mit der Untertitel, die verrückte Reise von zwei Halunken, die sich dachten, es geht ganz anders aus, Aliens kommen, die, weil so Die Hard stirbt langsam, wir kennen die Beispiele. Es wird übersetzt. Das verstehe ich noch. Ich finde es nicht gut, da geht auch sehr viel bei verloren, aber na ja, es macht noch Sinn. Aber es ist erstaunlich, wie viel, sag ich mal, Mut manche Übersetzer da auch einfach an Tag lesen. Weil ich würde ja sagen, nein, die Aufgabe des Übersetzers ist natürlich, dem Werk treu zu sein, aber du hast einen Film wie In Bruges und du hast dann Brügge Sehen und Sterben, was ein mega guter Titel ist, mega geiler Titel, In Bruges, einfach super lame, ein mega geiler Titel und vor allem auch dieses Sehen und Sterben, kannst du mittlerweile auch irgendwie zu ganz vielen Sachen sagen, das ist irgendwie so ein M. Irgendwie so dann irgendwas sehen und sterben, das hat so einen ganz eigenen Klang, so eine ganz eigene Melancholie. Ja, aber es überträgt komplett die Poesie des Films auch, finde ich. Also es ist so, es ist einfach so passend und cool und besser als das Original. Also es ist wirklich fantastisch. Und wer hatte die Idee einfach so, äh, Leute, ja, übrigens, in Bruges, ja, in Brügge, oder? Eine Anmerkung noch.
Wie war dein Name nochmal? Du bist neu, oder?
Fernando.
Hi, Fernando. Stell dir doch mal kurz vor, wo kommst du her, was hast du so gemacht in deinem Leben? Ich komme ursprünglich aus dem heißen Palermo, geboren am Strand, vaterlos aufgewachsen. Geboren am Strand? Ging ich eines Tages, ja, meine Mutter hatte sich ein wenig mit dem Strandausflug verschätzt, und so musste ich in meine erste Sandburg hineingeboren werden. Dann wurde ich gefangen genommen und ging nach Sibirien für sechzehn Jahre, wo ich lernte, was es heisst, ein Mann zu sein. Ich mach kurz das Licht ein bisschen, ich dimm das Licht ein bisschen. Bitte. Und dann lernte ich die Sprache der Menschheit lernen. In alle Länder der Welt fuhr ich, nur um zu verstehen, wie Menschen denken, wie sie fühlen und wie sie das durch ihre Sprache ausdrücken.
Wenn dann doch.
Denn die menschliche Erfahrung ist so viel grösser, als jeder einzelne Mensch lernen kann, weil man in seiner Sprache gefangen ist.
Und ich habe den Schlüsselbund der Sprache bekommen und ich habe jede Sprache entschlüsselt und ich weiss einfach, was man aussagen kann mit Sprache.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass unsere Zuschauer einen besseren Namen verdienen als in Brügge. Nein, man kann einfach übersetzen kann jeder. Nein, wir müssen diesen Film verstehen, wir müssen den Schlüssel aufmachen, wie wär's mit Brügge sehen und sterben. Ja, denken wir mal drüber nach. Ja, nochmal zurück. Richtig gut. Genial, ganz toll. Und die Franzosen machen das auch. Wer hätte es gedacht? Klar, ich glaube, es gibt auch wenig Länder in Europa, die der englischen Sprache so abgeneigt sind wie die Franzosen. Das stimmt, ja. Das heißt, die übersetzen es deswegen auch. Das ist richtig. Aber jetzt kommt es. sie übersetzen es nicht auf Französisch, sondern es bleibt ein englischer Titel.
Und sie übersetzen es einfach in einen anderen englischen Titel.
So hieß es zum Beispiel.
Der Film Wild Things, Sex Crimes.
Der Film Runaway Bride, Just Married.
Ja, okay. Der Film Phone Booth. Colin Farrell, wir hatten es gerade von ihm. Ja. Bei Anruf, Mord. Nee. Ah, ja. Nicht auflegen. Nicht auflegen. In Deutsch. Das klingt wie ein Brettspiel, was sehr viel Spaß macht, ehrlich gesagt. Nicht auflegen. Phone Game. Phone Booth wird zu Phone Game. Es ist einfach auszusprechen.
Ja, Booth.
Le Booth.
Und jetzt Hangover.
Very bad trip.
Was natürlich ein Problem ist mit Hangover 2.
The worst trip.
Und dann kann noch Hangover 3.
Ja, gut.
Wir haben uns gesteigert in das Endliche. Bitte, die nicht noch ein verdammt nochmal. George Clooney's Up in the Air heißt In the Air, wo man sich fragen muss, warum die Mühe geben, überhaupt alles zu ändern. Ja, du musst alle Poster nochmal um, du musst es ab und einfach diese Arroganz zu sagen, nein, ich finde ohne Up klingt ein bisschen besser, Drop the Up. Drop the Up. Drop the Up. Wir haben uns eigentlich Gedanken gemacht, Up in the Air, also das macht schon... Nein, nein, nein, das ist falsch, wir streichen das, wir schreiben das alles nochmal um. Okay, Sie können auch selber Filme machen, ich verstehe nicht, warum Sie unsere Filme... Nein, nein, nein, meine Aufgabe ist es, die Filme von anderen zu verbessern, die Fehler von anderen Menschen zu korrigieren. Was würden Sie ohne mich machen? Sie würden Filme herausbringen, die unanschaubar sind, Up in the Air, das ist nichts. Sie ändern nur den Titel, sie ändern nichts am Film. Das ist nichts. Der Titel ist die Seele des Films. Ja, aber In the Air? Man weiss nicht wo, In the Air. Ja, das ist die Spannung, verstehen Sie? Das zieht Sie in den Kinosaal. Wir müssen alles ändern, Poster müssen wir ändern, den Trailer müssen wir ändern. Oder wie wäre es mit, nicht Up in the Air, sondern Sex in the Air. Sex Air. Up in the Sex. Denken Sie mal darüber nach. Ja, dann der Film Night and Day, mit Tom Cruise und Cameron Diaz. Night and Day, der Krieger. Ach so, der Ritter. Der Ritter, genau, und Tag. Cleveres Wortspiel haben sie übersetzt in Night and Day, Tag und Nacht. Sie haben das K weggenommen. Night and Day. Diese verdammten Amerikaner haben eine Fehler gemacht, das heißt Night mit N. Was soll das für ein Wort sein? Wie dumm kann man sein, sie haben alles, sie haben überall, die Tränen, überall, alles falsch. Wie dumm kann man sein, es heißt Night and Day, Tag und Nacht, das ist so. Amerikanisch, Arroganz, Arroganz. Einfach so, ne, das ist mir zu lustig, das ist ein Wortspiel, das kommt raus, Night and Day. The Other Guys mit Will Ferrell, Mark Wahlberg, Very Bad Cops.
Sie haben es auf jeden Fall in diesem Very Bad. Very Bad, ja. Killers, der Film mit Ashton Kutcher, Kiss and Kill, Date Night heisst Crazy Night. Es ist kein roter Faden erkennbar. Ja, warum nicht Rendezvous Night? Es ist doch ein roter Faden erkennbar. No Strings Attached heisst Sex Friends. Also es ist schon lustig. Es folgt wirklich nur diesem einen roten Faden, wenn Sex in den Titel passt. Irgendwie. Irgendwie. Rein da. Finde ich sehr gut. Finde ich richtig gut. Ja, aber gut, es ist nicht so einfach. Ich verstehe die Krux, wir wetten es häufig von Üetzern, also es ist natürlich wirklich nicht so einfach. Ich glaube, inzwischen sind sich auch alle bewusst, wie sehr viel Verantwortung dahinter steckt, weil halt alle auch die YouTube und TikTok-Videos kennen, wo Leute sich darüber lustig machen, wie etwas in anderen Sprachen ist. Ja, ich habe auch gehört, dass manchmal das Problem ist, dass es diesen Namen schon in der Sprache gibt. Also es gibt ja so dieses Taken-96-Hours-Problem oder sowas, wo man sich denkt, warum noch ein komplizierterer deutscher Name, also 96-Hours ist der deutsche Name, der noch schwerer auszusprechen ist als Taken. Aber da, glaube ich, gibt es schon irgendwie einen Roman aus den 70er Jahren von Elfriede Jelinek, der Taken heisst. Und deswegen kann man es nicht übersetzen.. Das heißt, du hast ja eigentlich die Macht, Namen einfach wegzunehmen, so dass die immer sich irgendwie dumme neue Namen überlegen müssen. So dass du, wenn jetzt schon, keine Ahnung, Hangover kommt raus, dann schreibst du ein Buch namens Hangover 2, so eine lyrische Reise in das Toskana der 80er Jahre, wo ich einen Großteil meiner Kindheit verbracht habe. Und natürlich haben die Übersetzer dann ein Problem, wenn Hangover zwei rauskommt, weil sie es nicht mehr so benennen können,
sondern sie müssten es dann so zwei verrückte Freunde in Las Vegas oder sowas benennen.
Aber lustig, dass du Elfriede Jelinek sagst, weil ich habe einen Wikipedia-Artikel offen von Gravity's Rainbow,
der ja auf Deutsch übersetzt wurde von Elfriede Jelinek, in Die Enden der Parabel, was natürlich ein mega geiler Titel. Enden oder Enten? Die Enden der Parabel. Gravity's Rainbow, unfassbar geil. Aber auch eine mutige Übersetzung. Super mutig, aber Gravity's Rainbow alleine ist schon sehr abstrakt. Aber der Titel hat so viel Lob bekommen, der deutsche Titel, weil er auch genauso lyrisch Dinge aufgreift, die im Buch eine Rolle spielen und irgendwie auch so ein bisschen Humor übertragen. Was auch jetzt auch viral geht, sind gerade so diese Vergleiche zwischen den Synchronsprechern, Sprecherinnen. Ja, ja, im Gardium Leviosa in allen Sprachen. Genau, und es ist der deutsche, also schon länger her, aber der deutsche Synchronsprecher von Smaug ist viral gegangen, weil er das beste Ende beim Hobbit hatte, wenn Smaug dann frei ist zum ersten Mal, Spoiler, und rumfliegt über diese Stadt, ich weiß nicht, wie die heißt, und dann sagt, ich bin Feuer, ich bin der Tod. Und das finde ich interessant. Und dass Deutsch immer noch so klischee-mäßig die böse Sprache ist. Ja, absolut. Und immer bei Bösewichten alle sagen, ja, Deutsch gewinnt die Version. Und sich auch alle international einig sind, dass wir die böse Sprache sind. Ja. Klar, wahrscheinlich hat es historisch einige Gründe. Du, das Leben ist ein Theaterstück und jeder hat seine Rolle. Und es heißt ja nicht, dass man so ist wie die Rolle, sondern du kannst die Rolle ja auch spielen einfach. Und Bösewichte sind beliebt am Ende bei einem Applaus. Total, klar, absolut. Okay, damit kann ich jetzt leben. Wir machen unseren Podcast in einer Sprache, die vor allem böse ist. Ja. Für viele Leute klingt es wahnsinnig böse. Die jetzt irgendwie wahrscheinlich furcht, kauernd vor Furcht irgendwie da sitzen und den Podcast hören,
die sagen, nein, dann kommen sie.
Wir müssen natürlich über die Oscars reden,
Oscar-Buzz ist natürlich
wichtig und da natürlich auch herzlichen Glückwunsch
an dem Westen nichts Neues.
Viermal abgestaubt, vier Trophäen abgestaubt,
toi, toi, toi,
viel Glück beim nächsten Mal,
vielleicht werden es beim nächsten Jahr noch mehr Oscars,
ich glaube, da sind noch mehr drin. Ja, bei dem zweiten Teil, der nämlich heisst
aus dem Westen immer noch
nichts Neues. Ich glaube, da sind
noch mal zehn weitere Oscars drin.
Im Englischen einfacher, Too Quiet
on the Western Front und es
Two is a Two.
Das ist ein geiles Poster.
Das ist ja ein richtig geiles Poster.
Mach das, mach das in Photoshop.
Nee, ich gehe zu Netflix und sag, ähm ...
Es gibt ja diese berühmte Geschichte wie ...
Ich weiss nicht mehr, weil es war.
Ich mein, Ridley Scott, da hat dann Aliens 2 gepitcht,
oder war es dann James Cameron, der Aliens 2 gemacht hat?
Ich weiss nicht mehr genau.
Herr Tietze, schön, dass Sie da sind, hier noch mal bei Netflix.
Wir kennen Sie ja mittlerweile ganz gut.
Also, hab ich's richtig verstanden,
Sie wollen einen Nachfolger zum Ersten Weltkrieg pitchen?
Ich mache mir Folgendes.
Schauen Sie mir nur zu. Da nehme ich einen Stift, ein Edding, permanent.
Kannst du Fakten?
Nee, guck auf ihr Whiteboard, dreh mich um, ich habe so einen langen, verschwörerischen Mantel an und ich schreibe einfach nur drauf,
too quiet on the Western Front und das two ist eine zwei. Und drehe ich mich wieder um. Naja, aber der Film erzählt das Ende des Ersten Weltkriegs, wie soll es denn danach weitergehen? Zweiter Weltkrieg. Oh mein Gott, sie sind ein Genie. Sie sind ein Genie. Es gibt diese berühmte Geschichte von, ich weiss, es war James Cameron, der dann das Sequel zu Aliens gepitcht hat, dem Alien-Film, und schreibt Alien ans Whiteboard, schreibt dann ein S dahinter, Aliens, und macht durch das S zwei Dollarzeichen. Oh, nice! Sehr schön. That's how the myth, the legend goes. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so passiert ist, aber inspiriert davon finde ich das gar nicht so schlecht. Und dann, 20 Jahre später, schreibt er an Zweitpot Avatar. Und jetzt passt auf, Avatar-sss. Second movie.
Avatars, more Avatars. Oder alle haben sich, selbst alle, die gar nicht mit diesem Meeting was zu tun hatten, kommen in den Raum, weil sie von dieser Aliens-Geschichte wussten. Ja. Kommen in den Raum, der Raum ist packed. Und er schreibt an die Tafel, Avatar, Doppelpunkt, the way of the water. Und der ganze Raum ist enttäuscht, wie ich beim Title-Reveal auch enttäuscht.
Nennst doch Avatars. Warum denn Way of the Water?
The Way of the Waters.
Genau, da kann er nur noch Teil drei, The Way of the Waters.
Sssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss Genau, da kann er nur noch Teil drei, The Way of the Water. Stell dir das mal vor, Avatar, Avatar The Way of the Water und Avatar The Way of the Waters als Teil drei. Einfach so, was soll das? Ich meine, er kann machen, was er will. Beide Filme waren extrem erfolgreich. Ja, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Aber so, ich glaube, so muss man das pitchen. Too quiet on the Western. Nee, du hast recht, wir müssen mit Oskar Bass sprechen. Ja, unbedingt. Also Oskar, eine unfassbare Nacht, so viel ist passiert. Und ganz viele Goldbuben haben den Besitzer gewechselt. Die mussten raus. Nee, die werden nicht abgegeben und dann wieder. Wie? Die wechseln nicht den Besitzer. Das ist kein Wanderpokal. Doch, na klar, natürlich. Du meinst schon, Williams muss dann mit seinem Ford-Car wieder fortfahren. Immer so nach 25 Jahren wird das dann so durchrotiert. Meinst du, es gibt unendlich viele Oscar-Statuetten oder was? Ja. Nein. Statue, Statue. Der Oscar hat damals 200 Stück gemacht. Und die werden jetzt immer wieder weitergegeben. Wenn man diesen Termin, manchmal ist bei Apple Kalender es halt weird, und dann wechselt und dann weiss man nicht genau und dann... Herr Washington, Sie müssten dann doch bitte Ihren Oscar abgeben. Herr Washington! Nein! Wir können Sie sehen! Denzel, bitte! Ich bin nur auf dem Klo, ich bin nur auf dem Klo. Ich hab mich hier... Ich bin nur auf dem Klo, keine Chance. Denzel, wir sehen Sie im Flur. Ich weiss.
Können wir den Oscar haben? Wir müssen los, die Verleihung ist heute Abend. Das Fenster auf. Hey.
Pst, das Fenster auf. Wer?
Deine liebgewordene Frau.
Meine liebgewordene Frau.
Okay.
Marie.
Kelly Washington?
Musst du gehen?
Nicht verraten. Nee, oder? Tochter? Ja, also so läuft das in Hollywood. Das ist manchmal auch eine sehr unglamourhafte Welt. Man denkt immer Glamour, Glitzer, aber nein. Carrie. Manchmal ist es auch einfach, ähm, nein, ich glaube nicht. Dein Lieblingsfilm, Triangle of Sadness, den du mir schon so oft empfohlen hast, hat von drei Nominierungen null Oscars bekommen. Applaus für Stefan Tietze, der mal wieder auf den falschen Film gesetzt hat dieses Jahr. Null Punkte, null Punkte. Dann Benchies of Inisharian, neunmal nominiert und null Oscars bekommen. Also nochmal Applaus für Stefan Tietze, der von neun Nominierungen,
von insgesamt, man könnte sogar insgesamt sagen,
zwölf Nominierungen für seine beiden Lieblingsfilme,
null Trophäen nach Hause gebracht hat.
Stefan, stark!
Weil wirklich, muss man ja auch sagen,
die Academy ist so bekannter Fans,
immer die besten Filme zu prämieren
und es nichts Politisches ist,
sondern einfach nur immer die besten,
künstlerisch anspruchsvollsten und tollsten, originellsten Dinge prämiert werden.
Er windet sich gerade am Boden, er hat sich auf den Boden geworfen und windet sich von links nach rechts hin und her. Ja, denn wer Preise gewinnt, der hat Recht und wer im Kino die besten Zahlen hat, gräbt sein Gesicht in die Ecke ein gerade. Ist doch am liebsten Avatar alle Oscars gegeben.
Ja, Avatar The Way of Water, vier Nominierungen. The Ways of the Waters. Eine Triföhe bekommen. Eine Triföhe für Avatar, das ist zu wenig. Es ist unglaublich, dass im Westen nichts Neues vier Oscars bekommen hat. Und zwar auch in super interessanten Kategorien. Ja, für so einen Scheissfilm. Nicht nur beste Fremdsprache, sondern auch nicht nur beste Fremdsprache, Deutsch, sondern auch für die interessanten Kategorien. Nicht nur beste Fremdsprache, sondern auch für die Filmmusik,
was er unheard of, ist gegen John Williams gewonnen,
Volker Bertelmann.
Ja, wir hören doch mal ganz kurz in die Filmmusik rein.
Wow!
Woo!
Oscar!
Wow, wow, wow! Da haben sie ihren Soundtrack für Teil zwei. So still war es dann doch nicht. Ich meine, ein Film Quiet on the Western Front gewinnt beste Filmmusik. Da muss man sich doch auch mal fragen. Sorry, haben wir noch so Anschweck? Not quite enough at the Western Front. It was just the right amount of quiet. I liked that most of the movie it was quiet and I could relax because most movies are just so overblown with soundtrack and music that I... Das kannst du nicht machen, Stefan. Vergiss es. Stefan, la la la la la la la la la la copyright infringement, copyright infringement, copyright infringement. Stefan, lalalalalala, Copyright Infringement, Copyright Infringement, Copyright Infringement. Stefan, bitte. Stefan, komm jetzt noch ein Oskar-Moment. Ja, ne? Stark. Ich mach das nicht nochmal nach. Eure Öhrchen müssen geschont werden. Ähm, ich bin super, also ich bin super stolz auf dich, dass ich Leute kenne. Ich bin super stolz entzückt, wollte ich sagen. Stefan, lass deine wahren Emotionen raus. Entzückt. Ich finde es so interessant und cool, dass mir als in Deutschland arbeitender Filmschaffender im weitesten Sinne, das zeigt, dass man nicht weg muss oder so und man auch hier gesehen werden kann. Du heisst ja so ungern. Und das war bei Haut-de-Sail auch schon so toll, dass man einfach jetzt in dieser Zeit, in der wir leben, in anderen Ländern rezipiert werden kann und geguckt werden kann. Und das ist total schön, das ist schon das Gefühl, so ein tolles Gefühl. Und dass dieser Volker Bertelmann, der, glaube ich, auch viel Tatorte und Musik und so gemacht hat, weiß ich nicht, wie wir mich so nah treten, aber jetzt dann von der Academy gehört wird, nominiert wird und jetzt auch noch prämiert wird, ist finde ich irre. Und auch, das habe ich bei Triangle of Sadness auch schon das Gefühl gehabt, in vollem Kino... Null Oscars? Null Oscars, genau, gar keinen Oscar bekommen. Das sollten die auf den DVD-Release draufstehen. Ja, null Oscars. Null, null. Neunummernierungen, null Oscars, Bad She's of Ever in Innesheim. Innesharon. Innesharon. Und ich hatte Gänsehaut, weil ich im vollen Kino saß, und da kam dieser schwedische Regisseur, der das Buch selber schreibt und selber filmt und man guckt das in Deutschland im vollen Kinosaal, total cool, haben die da auch geguckt, haben nominiert, quasi eingeladen, um dann zu verlieren jetzt, aber nee, ich find's cool. Also inzwischen Subtitles traveln, Leute gucken Filme im Original mit Subtitles dadurch ... Echt, wird das nicht übersetzt? Wird das nicht synchronisiert? Doch, wahrscheinlich auch, aber so gucken die Leute, glaube ich, eher inzwischen. Ja. Ich find's toll, ich find's toll. Herzlichen Glück auf jeden Fall an alle Gewinnerinnen und Gewinner. Herzlichen Glück. Herzliches Glück an alle, die dabei waren und die es sich angeschaut haben. Oscar-Basis ist für mich jetzt beendet. Das war alles? Das war der Oscar-Basis. Aber willst du nicht zum Gewinner sagen? Everything, everywhere, all at once? Habe ich gesehen, hat mir gut gefallen. Aber? Da schwingt ein Aber mit. Nee, ich war in München, ich habe Popcorn gegessen. Ja, die Umstände interessieren uns weniger. Ich habe salzig und süss gemischt. Aber deswegen mag niemand dein Leatherbox-Account. Weil du schreibst immer nur, was du während des Films gegessen hast und wo du ihn geguckt hast. Ja. Aber du kommst dann so wenig zum Inhalt und gibst auch nie Sternebewertungen. Na, aber pass auf, das Ding ist, es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten, gemischtes Popcorn zu machen. Es gibt ja einmal die Schichtmethode. Nee, der Film Everything Everywhere All at Once. Da wollte ich jetzt konkret einmal nachfragen, wie hat der dir gefallen. Ja, ja, ja, ja, hab ich gesehen. Weil die Sache ist, wenn du mit süss anfängst, dann musst du mit salzig aufhören. Okay. Und wenn du von oben dich nach unten arbeitest, willst du ja eigentlich eher mit süss, weil, sag mal so, salzig ist eine gute Ergänzung zu süss, aber salzig alleine ist eher nicht, also wenn ich sagen würde, ist eins von beiden alleine, würde ich sagen, süss. Aber besser ist gemischt. Und deswegen ist es immer ganz gut, Shoutout Museumslichtspiele in München, bestes Kino der Welt, weil die Schichten erst süss-salzig, dann einmal durchschütteln, dann süss-salzig, dann durchschütteln, süss-salzig und süss-ob drauf. Es klingt genau wie deine Avatar-Review. Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen in München übrigens. Ich weiß, und da ging es auch schon sehr ums Popcorn. Da dachte ich eigentlich, wir hätten das abgehakt oder so. Oder das wäre irgendwie eine clevere Satire auf den Film, dass das Popcorn spannender war als Avatar The Ways of the Waters. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber jetzt fängt es genauso an wie bei Everything, Every All You Want. Deswegen noch mal jetzt einmal ganz konkret, also wirklich unglaublich konkret diese Frage, dass man da fast gar nicht ausweichen kann. Wie hat dir der Film gefallen? Ja, also Everything Everywhere All At Once, zehn von zehn Popcorn, perfekt. Also wirklich perfekt. Und Kino war sauber. Wenn Leute deinen Film gesehen haben und die fanden ihn richtig schlecht und dann aber trotzdem was Positives sagen wollen. Also der Kinosaal war sehr sauber. Ja, das ist genau wie bei Lieferando, wenn man mal in die Bewertungen schaut, wie oft das Restaurant schlechte Bewertungen hat. Weil da sind manchmal richtig gute Restaurants, wie zum Beispiel Subway. Man kann nichts gegen Subway sagen. Hat trotzdem irgendwie nur zweieinhalb Sterne. Und dann guckt man rein und es ist immer die Lieferung, die sehr schlecht bewertet wird, die irgendwie ins Restaurant mit einfließt. Ich verstehe es nicht ganz. Ach so, okay. Oder fliegt es anteilig rein, weil das Restaurant eine Teilschuld hat, wenn es zu spät zubereitet irgendwie. Aber für die, Jesus, sorry, sorry, ich finde es so unprofessionell, wenn das passiert. Es tut mir das richtig leid. Ach, es passiert doch nur ein-, zweimal pro Folge. Ja. Dreimal wäre auch mega ruhig, ehrlich gesagt. Inzwischen haben wir beide die Chance, auf lautlos zu drücken. Ich habe mittlerweile sehr viele Sojasauce-Packungen, weil ich glaube... Gibt es mehr Sterne für mehr Sojasauce? Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe mittlerweile das Gefühl, also ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen. Ja, ich bestelle auch manchmal mehr. Ja, so. Weil so ein klassischer Sonntag, da schlafe ich aus und dann bestelle ich einmal gross für Mittagessen und Abendessen. Ich bestelle gleich alles zusammen, mehrere Gerichte und ja, das kann man natürlich
lesen als zwei Personen, drei Personen.
Bestellst du bei einem Restaurant,
bei einem Etablissement dann oder machst du ein Bang Bang?
Bestellst du bei zwei verschiedenen
Restaurants, dass die Fahrer
sich gegenseitig treffen können bei dir
und denken, was passiert hier?
Geil wäre,
wenn du beim gleichen Restaurant bestellst auf zwei verschiedenen Lieferseiten. Und dann so leicht unterschiedliche Ankunftszeiten, so 13 Uhr und 13.15 Uhr. Und du stehst dann mit so einer Stoppuhr und so einem Trainingsanzug und sagst, so geht das nicht Volt. Und mittlerweile habe ich das Gefühl, die wollen ihre Sojasauce loswerden. Weil teilweise, ich habe dann halt keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal so 16 Rollen oder so und da sind halt einfach wirklich 24 Sojasauce-Packungen. Also ich hab mehr als eine Sojasauce-Packung pro Sushi-Rolle, mehr als eine Packung pro Rolle. Und ich hab auch gedacht, was sind das denn Verwältnisse? Also entweder esse ich es komplett falsch, kann ja auch sein, es gibt ja so Sushi, wie man es richtig esst und falsch, vielleicht musst du es einfach komplett in Sojasauce ertränken und ich glaube, die haben einfach mittlerweile so einen riesigen Sack, wo die einfach wirklich so wütend, einfach so wahnsinnig viele Tüten reinhauen und auch Stäbchen, ich habe letztens zwölf Paar Stäbchen bekommen, ja, zwölf, also du bestellst so viel, du soll du dir zwölf Paar Stäbchen geben.
Also das ist doch albern. Ja, das müssen zwölf Personen sein.
Ich glaube, die haben einfach wie so
einen Sack,
der oben an der Decke hängt.
Dann haben die so eine Schleuse und machen das auf und
dann fällt er einfach rein.
Und es ist einfach viel, viel zu viel.
So ein Kohle betriebener Stäbchen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob dir das auch schon mal aufgefallen ist,
aber bei Sushi ist nicht einfach zu bestellen. Nicht nur heißen gleiche Gerichte oft anders, sondern es gibt auch unterschiedliche Grade an Fanciness des Sushi-Etablissements. Und Sushi ist eh immer schon sehr teuer. So, und dann ist es mir neulich passiert, dass ich sehr unzufrieden war mit meiner letzten Sushi-Bestellung und bin dann geswitcht zu einem anderen Sushi-Restaurant, was sehr gute Bewertungen hatte bei Lieferando. Und dann habe ich da bestellt für ungefähr das gleiche Budget und bei mir kam so wenig an, weil ich habe nicht nachgelesen, wie viel das dann jeweils ist. Ich war meine acht Röllchen gewohnt und so. Und dann war irgendwie so ein Gericht, hat dann so acht Euro gekostet.
Und alles, was kam, war ein so ein Nigiri-Ding.
Es war, ich habe da nicht nachgelesen, weil es hieß auch alles ungefähr gleich.
Und ich wollte einfach schnell bestellen und dachte mir, was kann schon passieren?
Es kann sehr viel passieren beim Sushi-Bestellen.
Und am Ende, es kam dann irgendwie für Superfix, ich habe auch so alles, ich habe so nicht gefrühstückt und dann so Mittag und Abend erst in einem gepackt und so.
Es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen, aber was ankam, es war so wenig, es war so wenig, es war nicht mal eine halbe Mahlzeit fürs gleiche Geld, wovon ich sonst irgendwie Mittag und Abend gegessen habe. Du bestellst für 16 Euro und kriegst am Ende zwei Teile, wo auch der Lieferant sich denkt, wo komme ich hier an, was passiert das hier? Ich hatte durchgebrochene Stäbchen bei mir drin, im Sinne von nicht mal einer. Das ist eine Kriegserklärung, in der japanischen Kultur heißt das aber sowas wie, du hast unsere Familienehre beleidigt. Aber es war das leckerste Sushi, was ich jemals gegessen habe. Aber es war viel zu wenig, viel zu teuer. Deswegen würde ich vorschlagen, falls ihr ein Sushi-Restaurant habt mit Bestellservice, macht noch so einen Counter, dass wenn die Kunden die Sachen anklicken, ihr unten zusammenfasst, wie viele Teile. Dass so irgendwie Sommerbox, Goldener Schwan, die Tausend Königreiche, und unten steht, wie viele Teile insgesamt, wie viele Sushi-Teile halt einfach. Dass man da einen Überblick hat, weil man weiß ja irgendwann, okay, ich brauche 20, ich brauche 30, ich brauche 19. Und dann kannst du dir einfach das zusammenklicken und siehst unten und hast keine böse Überraschung. Deswegen bitte nochmal den Teile-Counter, wo du einfach zusammengefasst bekommst, wie viel kriege ich am Ende. Ja, es kann sehr viel passieren. Also deswegen, ich weiss nicht irgendwie, man trifft sich irgendwie, das ist ein drittes Date oder so, man trifft sich dann schon mal bei einem zu Hause und dann ist Sushi, da kann auch viel schief gehen, ich weiß nicht, ob Sushi das beste Gericht ist. Es ist cool, bevor das Date ankommt? Nee, manchmal zusammen, ist auch irgendwie gemeinsam, kann man schon mal sehen, wie ist der Gegenüber beim Bestellen. Hier kann sich man herausstellen, dass es alles nichts wird. Was sind da Red Flags für dich? Bei mir ein Red Flags wäre, oh, wollen wir nicht das zusammen essen? Ja, ja. Und raus, sofort, dismissed. Nein, jeder bestellt... Ich bin gerade jetzt angekommen. Ich bin doch gerade... Nee, Entschuldigung, dann lass die Jacke an, so, und raus. Nein, wir machen ja kein, wir nehmen das zusammen und dann probiert jeder mal bei jedem. Nein, du bestellst deine Sachen, ich bestell deine Sachen. Wenn jemand satt ist, lass mich ausreden. Wenn jemand satt ist, kann er am Ende gerne noch hier und da verteilen und man kann gucken, was passiert. Aber nicht, wir nehmen es zusammen. Ich will wissen, dass das meins ist und dass ich satt werde, okay? Wir hatten noch so schön, Florentin. Ja, und ja, den Ring kannst du behalten, ist mir egal, hau ab. Ja, da hätte es mir glühen sollen, dass du mit einem zweiten Date mir einen Ring gibst. Ich hab dich einfach falsch eingeschätzt. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass du so eine Bestellerin bist. Ich will dich nicht mehr sehen. Ja, ist ja okay. Hier sind die Stäbe. Das ist eine Kriegserklärung. Ja, allerdings. Nee, das geht nicht. Das geht gar nicht. Kriegsbeil wird ausgegraben. Nee. Es wird ausgegraben, ja. Es wird begraben. Was sagst du, zu Dips, zu viele Dips, ist das eine Red Flag bei dir? Zu viele Dips bestellen. Zu viele Dips bestellen, noch zu viel Extrazeug? Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an. Ich bin Purist, generell. Ein Nigiri, mehr brauche ich nicht. Auf meinen Pommes Frites wirst du nichts finden. Keine Mayo, keine Ketchup, keine Curry. Wirklich, du isst einfach Pommes Frites? Pommes Frites, ich bin einfach, da bin ich ein Purist. Auf meinem Burger am liebsten, am liebsten ein Salatblatt, so diese Burgersoße, da vertraue ich den Leuten, die das machen, Patty und Käse. Ich will da nicht irgendwie noch super viel drauf haben, gut, wenn ihr dann irgendwie eine coole Tomate habt, macht doch einfach eine Scheibe Tomate. Das ist die Notiz, wenn ihr eine coole Tomate habt, gebt mir eine Scheibe, aber wenn nicht, dann nicht. Er spart mir irgendwie das Birne-Walnuss-Chutney oder so einen Scheiss. Auch beim Steak, bitte, einfach nur Steak. Ich will keine Soße, ich will keinen Chimichurri. Ich liebe Chimichurri, versteht mich nicht falsch. Aber bitte, Finger weg. Ich möchte eigentlich nur ... Also dann bist du ja eher Anti-Dip. Anti-Dip, aber ich bin super offen für Leute, die Dips bestellen. Was ist mit Pizza-Dip? Ich möchte sterben. Ich möchte, dass du jetzt die Wohnung vollstest. Drittes Date und er sagt, ich würde mir eine Tonne nehmen mit Aioli-Dip, eine Pizza-Dip. Das ist so ein grosses Napf, so ein grosses Näpfchen. Aber ich bin beim dritten Date, wo man schon erwarten könnte erwarten könnte, dass danach was passiert, irgendwann mal im Laufe des Abends und sich dann eine Thunfischpizza mit Aioli Knoblauchdipp zu bestellen, ist eine herbe Ansage. Ja, aber finde ich auch ein bisschen sympathisch. Ich auch. Einfach so, ich habe da Bock drauf, ich esse es gerne. Und kein Performancedruck mehr. Ja Ja, genau. Weil wir gucken wahrscheinlich einfach nur, er meinte wirklich Netflix im Schirm. Er meinte, er kommt rüber und wir gucken einfach nur Netflix, bis er wieder geht. Kann auch eine totale große Entlastung sein. Einerseits finde ich es irgendwie abartig, Pizzadip, aber andererseits mag ich auch den Exzess. Einfach zu sagen, die italienische Kochkunst hat seit Jahrtausenden dieses Gericht einfach perfektioniert, keine Zutat zu viel und du sagst, nee, drück das nochmal in Barbecue-Sauce rein. Aber mir geht es auch so, bei Pizza habe ich dann, ich habe verschiedene Lieferservices für verschiedene Arten Lust auf Pizza. Es gibt nämlich verschiedene, also ich bestelle manchmal bei Pizza Hut, das sind meine Exzessabende, da habe ich dann Käserrand, Pizzabrötchen, gibt mir so Dip und doppelt Käse. Gibt es noch mehr Käse? Kann ich noch mehr Käse zum Extra-Käse bestellen? Ja, sicher. Natürlich. Möchten Sie Käse im Käse im Rand haben? Ja, okay. Wunderbar, kein Problem. Möchten Sie statt dem Rand einfach ein riesiges Stück Käse haben? Ist das möglich? Ja, klar. Sie könnten auch statt einer Pizza einfach ein riesen Leib-Cummon-Bear haben. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich bei Cheese-Hut angerufen habe. Rein Können Sie sich umbenennen in Cheese Hut? Machen wir gerne, kein Problem. Möchten Sie noch ein bisschen extra Käse umdrauschen? Pizza Hut, fuck it. Fuck it, cheese it. Aber das ist ... So esse ich dann, wenn ich da Bock drauf hab, dann hab ich aber manchmal auch Bock auf richtig geile italienische Pizza. So eine schöne sizilianische. Ja, oder napolitanische. Wird schön angerufen, nebenan gehe ich da hin. Das ist toll. Aber bei verschiedenen, ich weiß nicht, bei anderen Gerichten oder Nationalitäten gibt es das glaube ich nicht. Aber es ist das gleiche Gericht, was ich über unterschiedliche Arten konsolieren möchte. Ja, total. Ich finde es ein bisschen stören, wenn die Pizza grösser ist als der Teller. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, viele Pizzerien nehmen das so als Qualitätsmerkmal, dass so eine gute, knusprige, flache Pizza muss riesengroß sein und dann einfach viel zu groß für den Teller. Ich sage, Leute, ihr wisst, wie groß der Teller ist. Oder holt euch einen größeren Teller. Es spart ja keinen Platz, einen kleinen Teller zu haben, wo eine riesige Pizza drauf ist, wo ich schon mal direkt überfordert bin. Mach das nicht. Hol dir doch einfach mal so ein schönes, großes Holzbrett. Ja, und das bringe ich dann mit ins Restaurant oder was und leg das dann selber hin oder was in Alufolie. Ach so, ich dachte, bei dir geht mein Gehirn sofort in Richtung, du siehst zu Hause und bestellst dir das. Ja, deswegen bestelle ich ja nur noch, weil ich da nicht sitzen will. Ich meine, klar, es ist psychologisch natürlich schon clever, zu sagen, hier ist der Teller, das ist deine Erwartungshaltung und die Pizza ist einfach mal vier, fünf Zentimeter im Durchmesser größer und denkst dir, geil. Aber dann kommt die Ernüchterung, wenn du dann da irgendwie so rumfuhrwerken musst und um es dann anzuschneiden, brauchst du ja Druck, du brauchst ja den Teller, dann schiebst du den ganzen Lappen halb wieder über den anderen Teller raus, dann hängt es irgendwie dein Date auf der Hand, du denkst, weil du sitzt natürlich neben. Als alter Gentleman sitzt man sich natürlich auf der Bank daneben und schaut gemeinsam in den Raum und dann ist alles wieder auch unangenehm. Bist du zu Hause jemand, der dein Besteck und dein Geschirr herausnimmt, um das, was du bestellst, zu essen? Also nimmst du, holst du dann deinen grossen Teller und machst dann die Pizza auf den Teller oder isst du die Pizza aus dem Karton? Natürlich aus dem Karton. Außer ein Gericht tatsächlich, wenn ich indisch bestelle, da kommen verschiedene Elemente zusammen und die füge ich dann auf dem Teller zusammen. Alle kochen heiß? Alle fucking heiß. Ich weiß nicht, wie indisch, also indische Lieferdienste sind für mich ohnehin ein Mysterium. Einerseits ist Essen schmeckt jedes Mal anders, selbst wenn du das gleiche Gericht nimmst, jedes Mal anders. Und ist nicht schlecht, aber die Konsistenz ist sehr klein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das was mit der indischen Kochkunst zu tun hat. Und zweitens, es ist so fucking heiß. Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen. Tomaten. Viele Tomaten, hohe spezifische Werbekapazität. Ja, das. Einfach, also du meinst dann, die Kiste ist voller Tomaten oder was, indem die das transportieren oder die hauen einfach überall? Weil wir beide wahrscheinlich Butter Chicken Fans sind, wo natürlich Tomate eine Hauptzutat ist, die eine krasse Wärmespeicherkapazität hat. Ich glaube, das ist es. Tomate, die Menge, die Dichte an Tomate im indischen Essen. Warum ist dann die Pizza nicht so alt? Ich meine, die Pizza hat natürlich auch die denkbar ungünstigste Form, um Wärme zu speichern. Da würde ich schon mal, warum hat sich Pizza so als Lieferantending durchgesetzt, wenn es eigentlich... Deswegen bestelle ich Calzone. Mir piace la Calzone. Das wäre für mich eine Red Flag. Wollen wir Pizza bestellen? Ja, ich nehme die Calzone. Okay, raus. Raus. Ich habe gesagt, wir versuchen es nochmal. Ich habe mich jetzt extra von den Dips ferngehalten. Du schmeißt mich wieder raus. Sorry. Aber wie, isst man eine Calzone auch mit der Hand, oder gäbelt man da da rum? Beide Hände und wie so ein Kebab. Wird einfach reingebissen, dann wird sich verbrannt. Genau, ich hätte Angst vor der Magma. Holy shit. Ja, weil da hast du nämlich Magma. Und bei Pizzen nicht. Na gut. Naja, wir wünschen euch weiterhin guten Appetit und eine schöne Woche. Ich hoffe, ihr kommt gut durch die Woche. Ich hoffe, der Oscar-Bass hat euch nicht zu sehr zugesetzt. Kommt runter, entspannt euch ein bisschen und holt vor allem die tollen Filme nach, die gewonnen haben. Und wir haben vor allem jetzt versucht, heute eine Folge zu machen, wo sich niemand ekeln muss, wo wir nicht über Körper essen. Schön über Essen. Nein, über Essen reden wir, alles entspannt. Ich muss dir ein Video zeigen, ich habe jetzt auch ein Video aufgenommen mit meinem Ohrending
und er ist so ekelhaft, weil das ist halt
alles voll, riesige Brocken
von Schleimig und Gelben
und das so kriegst du meine Augen
die Augen wurden aufgeschnitten
du musst es richtig daran reissen
und mach's gut, wir heben ab, tschau Ciao.